The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR STRANG: OK,
so this is the start --
I won't be able to do
it all in one day --
of what I think of as the number
one model in applied math,
in discrete implied
math, I'll say.
Let me review what
our four examples are.
Just so you see the big picture.
So the first example was
the springs and masses.
That was beautiful.
It's simple.
The masses are all in a
line, and the matrix K,
the free-fixed and
fixed-fixed and free-free
come out closely related
to our K, T, B matrices.
So that was the
natural place to start,
and actually we
also got a chance
to do the most important
equation in time.
Ku''-- Sorry, Mu''+Ku=0.
So that was a key example.
Then least squares.
Very important, I'm
already getting questions
from the class about problems
that come up in your work,
least square problems.
Maybe I'll just mention that
the professional numerical guys
don't always go
to A transpose A.
If it's a badly
conditioned problem,
and that conditioning is
a topic that was in 1.7
and we'll eventually
come back to, if it's
a badly conditioned problem,
matrix A then-- A transpose
A kind of makes it worse.
So there's another way to
orthogonalize in advance.
And if you're working
with orthogonal vectors,
or orthonormal vectors,
numerical calculations
are as safe as they can be.
Yeah.
Wall Street is more
like A transpose A.
And the orthonormal
is the safe way.
Alright, this is
today's lecture.
You'll see the matrix a
for a graph, for a network.
It's simple to construct, and
it just shows up everywhere.
Because networks are everywhere.
And, just, looking
ahead, trusses
are there partly because
they're the most fun.
You'll enjoy trusses.
I mean, it's kind
of fun to figure out
is the truss going
to collapse or not.
It's good.
And actually, what's the
linear algebra in there?
The collapsing or not will
depend on solutions to Au=0.
Let me just recall
the equation Au=0.
If A is our key matrix
in each example,
it's different in each example.
And we sort of hope that
Au=0 doesn't have solutions,
or that it has
solutions we know.
Because if Au=0 has solutions
that's the case where A
transpose A is not invertible
and we have to do something.
Very useful to review.
What were the solutions to
Au=0, in the case of springs?
Well, there were some
in the free-free case.
The all ones vector
was the solution u,
or all constant
was the solution u
in the free-free case and that's
why we couldn't invert it.
But the fixed-free
or the fixed-fixed,
when we have one
support or two supports,
that removed the
all ones solution.
Good.
Least squares, we assume
there weren't any.
We assumed-- Because we
wanted to work directly
with A transpose A,
the normal equations,
so we assumed that the
columns of A were independent.
We assumed that there were no
non-zero solutions to Au=0.
Because if there
were, that would
have made A
transpose A singular,
and we would have had to
do something different.
Here, this'll be a
lot like this one.
Today, once you see A, you'll
spot the solutions to Au=0.
This is A for a network.
And the solution is going to
be that same guy, all ones.
And that only tells us again
that we have to ground a node,
I may use an electrical term.
Grounding a node is like
fixing a displacement.
Once you've fixed one
of those, say at zero,
whatever, but zero's
the natural choice.
Once you've said one of the
potentials, one of the voltages
is zero, then you
know all the rest.
You can find all the
rest from our equations.
So this is like this in
having this all ones solution.
And as you'll see
with trusses, that
could, depending on the
truss, have more solutions.
And if there are
more solutions that's
when the truss collapses.
So the trusses need more
than just a single support
to hold up a whole truss.
OK.
So that's the Au=0.
Now we're ready for
the lecture itself.
Graphs and networks.
OK, let me start
with, what's a graph.
A graph is a bunch
of nodes and some
or all of the
edges between them.
Let me take just a particular
example of a graph.
And this of course
you spot in the book.
Oh and everybody
recognized that,
and it's probably now corrected,
that in the homework where
it said 3.4 it meant
2.4, of course.
And this is Section 2.4 now.
Let me draw a different graph.
Maybe it'll have four
nodes, at those four edges,
let me put in a fifth edge.
OK, that's a graph.
It's not a complete
graph because I
didn't include that extra edge.
It's not a tree because
there are some loops here.
So complete graphs
are one extreme where
all the edges are in.
A tree is the other
extreme, where you
have a minimum number of edges.
It would only take
probably three edges.
So just while we're
looking at it,
there are a bunch
of possible trees
that would be sort
of inside this graph.
Sub-graphs of this graph, if
I knock out those two edges
I have a tree, going out.
Or a tree could be like this.
Anyway, five edges is in this
graph, six in a complete graph,
it would be three
edges in a tree.
OK, and the number
of edges is always m.
So five edges.
And the number of nodes
is always n, for nodes.
So A will be five by four.
OK.
And it's called, so we get a
special name in this world,
it's called the incidence
matrix of the graph.
The incidence matrix.
Or, of course,
these things come up
so often they have
other names, too.
But incidence matrix is
a pretty general name.
OK, I have to number
the nodes just
so we can create the matrix
A. One, two, three, four.
And I have to number the edges.
If I don't number them, I
don't know which is which.
So let me call this edge
one, from one to two,
and I'll draw an
arrow on the edges.
So from one to
two, maybe this'll
be edge two, from one to three.
This'll be edge three.
Oh no, let me put edge three
there, would be a natural one,
say from two to three.
And how about edge four
there, from two to four.
And edge five going
from three to four.
OK, so now I have numbered,
I've identified the nodes,
and I've identified the edges.
And there were five
edges and four nodes.
Usually m is bigger than n.
We're in this--
Except for trees,
m will be at least
as large as n.
And I've put arrows
on, so you could
say it's a directed graph.
Because I've given a direction.
You'll see that the directions,
those arrow directions, which
are just to tell me which way
current should count as plus,
if it's with the arrow, or which
way it should count as minus
if it's against the arrow.
Of course, current
could go either way.
It's just, now I have a
convention of which is plus
and which is minus.
OK, so now let me tell
you the incidence matrix.
So everybody can
get it right away,
how do you create
this incidence matrix?
A five by four.
So it's going to have five
rows, one for every edge.
So what's the row for edge one?
And it's got four columns,
one for every node.
So these are the nodes.
Nodes one, two, three, four.
So there's a column for every
node and a row for every edge.
OK, edge one.
This is just going to tell me
everything about the graph.
So exactly what's in that
picture will be in this matrix.
If I've erased one,
I could reproduce it
by knowing the other one.
OK, edge one goes from
node one to node two.
So it leaves node one,
I'll put a minus one there.
In the first column.
And a plus one in
the second column.
Edge one doesn't touch
nodes three and four.
So there you go,
that's edge one.
Let me do edge two
and then you'll
be able to fill in the rest.
So edge two goes from one to
three, minus one, and a one.
Edge three goes from two to
three, I'll just keep going.
Minus one and a one.
Edge four goes from two to four.
And edge five goes
from three to four.
OK.
Simple, right?
Got it.
That matrix has got all
the information that's
in my picture, and the matrix--
But the point about matrices
is, they do something.
They multiply a vector
u to produce something.
They have a meaning beyond
just a record of the picture.
So A is a great thing.
In fact, what does it do?
Let's see.
So that's the matrix
A that we work with.
Oh, first tell me about Au=0.
Because we brought up
that subject already.
Are those four
columns independent?
I've got four columns,
they're sitting
in five-dimensional space,
there's plenty of room
there for four
independent vectors.
Are these four columns
independent vectors?
No.
No, they're not.
Because what combination
of them produces the zero
vector? [1, 1, 1, 1].
If I take that column plus
that, plus that, plus that,
I'm multiplying by-- So, A,
I'll just put that up here
and then I won't have
to write it again.
A times [1, 1, 1, 1],
is five zeroes.
So that u, that
particular u, of all ones,
is, I would say, in the
null space of the matrix.
The null space is all
the solutions at Au=0.
In other words, so
these four columns,
tell me about the
geometry again.
These four columns, if I take
all their combinations, yeah.
Think about this.
If I take all four
combinations, all combinations,
any amount of this
column, this column,
this column, that
fourth column, those
are all vectors in
five-dimensional space.
Now, this isn't
essential but it's good.
Do you have an idea
of what you'd get?
What would you get if you took,
so this, think of four vectors,
pointing along, take
all their combinations,
that kind of fills in.
Whatever fill in may mean.
And what does it fill in?
What do I get?
What's your image?
Frankly, I don't know.
I can't visualize
five-dimensional space.
That well.
But still, we can use words.
What do you think?
You get a something subspace.
You got a something,
you get something flat.
I don't know if you do.
It's pretty flat, somehow.
Like I'm just asking you to
jump up from a case we know.
Where we had columns in
three-dimensional space
and we took a combination
and they gave us a plane.
Right, when they were dependent?
Now, how would you
visualize the combinations
in five-dimensional space?
Just for the heck of it?
It's some kind of a
subspace, I would say.
And what's its dimension, maybe
that's what I want to ask you.
What's the dimension?
Do I get, like, a
four-dimensional subspace
of five-dimensional space
when I take the combinations
of these particular four guys?
Yes or no?
Do I get a
four-dimensional subspace,
whatever that may mean?
No.
Right answer, I don't.
I don't.
Somehow the dimension of that
subspace, whatever I get,
isn't four because
this fourth guy is not
contributing anything new.
The fourth one is a
combination of the first three.
So I get a
three-dimensional subspace.
The rank of this
matrix is three.
If you allow me to
introduce that key word,
rank is the number of
independent columns.
It tells you how big
the matrix really is.
You know, if the
matrix, if I pile
on a whole lot of zero
columns, or a lot of zero rows,
the matrix looks bigger.
But of course it
isn't truly bigger.
The heart of the matrix,
the core of the matrix
is somehow just three.
And actually, I tell you
now and we'll see it happen,
can I tell you the key
result in the first half
of linear algebra?
It's this.
That if I have three independent
columns, and by the way
any three are independent,
it's just all four
together are dependent.
This has three
independent columns,
then the great fact is, it
has three independent rows.
That's kind of fantastic.
Since it's such a beautiful
and remarkable and basic fact,
look at the rows.
That what linear
algebra is all about.
Looking at a matrix by
columns, and then by rows,
and seeing what are
the connections.
And the connection
is, the key connection
is, that these five rows,
now what space are they in?
What what space
are these rows in?
Four-dimensional space.
They only have four components.
So I had four columns in
5-D, I have five rows in 4-D.
But now, are those
five rows independent?
Let me just ask that question.
Are those five
independent rows, are
they pointing in
different directions,
or could any combination
give the zero vector in 4-D,
looking at those five rows?
What do you say, wait a minute.
Five vectors, in
four-dimensional space?
Dependent, of course.
Right.
So they're dependent.
There couldn't be five
independent vectors in 4-D.
But are there four in
this particular case?
And here's the great
fact, no, there are three.
If there are three independent
columns and no more,
then there are three
independent rows and no more.
And we'll get to see which
rows are independent.
And which are not.
That's a question
about A transpose,
and we haven't got
to A transpose yet.
OK, are you OK with
that incidence matrix?
Because this is like the
central matrix of our subject.
We can figure out A transpose
A, that's kind of fun.
If I do A transpose
A then you'll
see the core computations
of this neat section.
So if I do A transpose A, so I'm
going to bring in A transpose
and you know that I'm not just
bringing it in from nowhere,
that networks--
the balance law is
going to involve A transpose.
So let's just anticipate.
What do you think A
transpose A looks like?
Now, how am I going
to do this for you?
May I write-- May I
erase this for a moment,
and try to squeeze
in A transpose here?
So that you can multiply it
by sight and see the answer,
and then you'll see the pattern.
That's the great
thing about math.
You do a few
examples, and you hope
that a pattern reveals itself.
So let me show A transpose.
So now I'm going to take that
column and make it a row.
I'm going to take that
column and make it a row,
it's going to be a little
squeezed but we can do it.
Take that column,
[0, 1, 1, 0,  -1].
And the last column,
[0, 0, 0,  1, 1].
OK.
So I just wrote
A transpose here.
And now could you help
me with A transpose A.
Which is the key matrix
in the graph here.
What size will it be?
Everybody knows it's
going to be square,
it's going to be symmetric,
and just tell me the size.
Four by four.
Right, we have a four by
five times a five by four,
we're expecting this
to be four by four.
And what's the first entry?
Two.
Right, take row one,
dot it with column one.
I get two ones and then a bunch
of zeroes, so I just get a two.
What's the next entry?
Take row one against column two,
can you do that in your head?
Row one, column two, the top one
is going to hit on a minus one,
and I think that's
all there is, right?
Then this one hits a zero
and those three zeroes, so.
And then what about
the next guy here?
A minus one.
And the last guy?
A zero.
So that's row one
of A transpose A.
Can I just look at that
for a moment before I fill
in the rest?
And then, when you fill in the
rest it'll confirm the idea.
Why do I have a zero there?
Why did a zero appear
in the 1, 4 position?
If I look back at
the graph, what
is it about nodes one and four
that told me ahead of time?
You're going to get a zero
in that A transpose A.
Everybody see what
nodes one and four are?
Yeah, say it again.
Not connected.
No edge.
Here there was an edge
from node one to two.
Here is an edge from
node one to three.
Those both produce
the minus ones.
And on the diagonal came
the two to balance it.
What does that two represent?
That two represents
the number of edges
that do go into node one.
See, that row is
all about node one.
So there are two edges into
it, and then an edge out,
and an edge out, and the
edge out and the no edge.
OK.
So, now I know it's going
to be a symmetric matrix,
so I could speed up
and fill those in.
What's the next entry here?
What's the guy on this diagonal?
So that's row two
against column two,
so I have a one
there, a one there,
a one there, that makes a three.
Why a three?
Because there are,
yeah, you got it.
There are three edges
into node number two.
Three edges into
node number two,
and now I'm going to have some
minus ones off the diagonal
for those edges.
So what are these
entries going to be here?
They're both minus ones.
Edge two is connected to
all three other nodes.
So I'm going to see a minus
one and a minus one there,
and it's going to be symmetric.
And I'm nearly there.
Of course, I'm
describing a pattern
that you're just
seeing unfold, but I'm
doing it that way so
that you'll feel hey,
I can write down A
transpose A, or check it
quite quickly, without
doing this complete matrix
multiplication.
So what number goes there?
That's to do with
node three, and I
see node three connected
to all three other nodes,
and so what do you expect there?
Minus one there, and
a minus one there,
and what do you expect here?
Two.
And so now I have my matrix.
The A transpose A matrix.
And that's square
and it's symmetric.
Now I ask you, is it
positive definite?
Or is it only semi-definite?
Right, we know that A transpose
A is always positive definite
in the best case.
But only positive
semi-definite if it's singular,
if there's some vector
in its null space,
if a transpose a times
some vector gives zero.
If some combination
of those columns
gives me the zero column.
Which is it?
Have I got a singular matrix
or an invertible matrix here?
Singular.
Why singular?
Because a had some
solutions to Au=0.
So if Au equaled zero, then
I could multiply both sides
by A transpose, that same
u, A transpose times zero
will still be zero, it might
be a different size zero,
but it'll be zero.
And what's the u, then?
It's the all ones vector.
What am I saying about the
columns of A transpose A?
They're dependent.
They add up-- Because
it's the [1, 1, 1, 1]
vector that's guilty,
every row adds to zero.
Every row adds to zero.
Let me just say for a moment,
introduce two notation
for the diagonal matrix.
D, that's the diagonal matrix,
two, three, three, two.
And then I'll put
in a minus sign,
and this is and I'll
call it W. So you
can pick out what D and W are,
but let me do it for sure.
So D, the degree matrix.
See, this is this is like fun
because I'm not doing anything
yet.
I'm just giving names here.
Two, three, three, two.
The degree of a node,
the degree means
how many edges go from it.
How many edges touch it.
And W is also a
great matrix, it's
called the adjacency matrix.
It's also beautiful.
Now it'll have plus ones
because I wanted minus W,
so it has, these nodes are
not adjacent to themselves
but it's got this
one and this one
and this one this one and
that one, and that's a zero.
So there are five,
the adjacency matrix
tells me which nodes are
connected to which other nodes.
And of course the connections
are going both ways.
So I see five ones
from five edges.
And I see five more
ones below the diagonal,
because the edges are
connecting both ways.
Ones connected to three, and
three is connected to one.
One is not connected to
four, and four is not
connected to one.
One is not connected to itself.
By an edge.
If we allowed, like, little
self loops, then a one
could appear on the diagram.
But we don't.
OK, so that's D and W.
Here are the key matrices.
This is actually, I venture to
say that any afternoon at MIT
there's a seminar that
involves these matrices.
One name for this is
the graph Laplacian,
from Laplace's equation.
And we'll see pretty soon
where that name's coming from.
But it's there.
And should I think, I think I
should, just about networks.
Like where, does the
networks come from?
I think we've got
networks all around us.
Right?
Electrical networks are the
simplest, maybe in some ways
the simplest to visualize.
So that's the example,
that's the language I'll use.
Now, I get a network,
I use the word network
when there's a c_1,
c_2, c_3, c_4, c_5.
Those extra numbers.
I've got the A,
and now the network
comes from the C part,
that diagonal matrix.
And if I'm talking electricity,
these could be resistors.
Instead of springs,
they're resistors.
So it's the conductance
in those five resistors,
are c_1, c_2, c_3, c_4, and c_5.
So I'm ready for that.
Ready for the C matrix,
because we got the A matrix.
And we've got A transpose
A, but the applications
throw in the C matrix also.
What are other
applications, I was
saying, like this one is the
one, I'll use the word current,
for flow in the edges, or
I'll use the word flow.
A network of oil, or
natural gas, or water pipes
would be just that, and
then the electrical-- People
study the-- Professor
Verghese in Course 6 studies
the electric grid.
The US electric
grid, or the western,
often the western half
of the US electric grid.
So that's got a
whole lot of things.
Pumping stations.
You see it?
Actually, the world
wide web, the internet,
is a giant network that people
would love to understand.
And the phone company
would love to understand
those networks of phone calls.
I mean, those are really, that's
what, giant businesses are
are dependent on understanding
and maintaining networks.
OK, so I'm going
to use resistors.
Of course, I'm staying linear.
And I'm staying steady state.
So by staying linear there
aren't any transistors
in this net.
By staying steady state,
there aren't any capacitors
or inductors.
Those guys would
be linear elements,
but they would be coming in
a time-dependent problem.
A u_(tt) problem.
And I'm just staying now with
Ku=f, I'm trying to create K.
The stiffness matrix, which
maybe here we might call
the conductance matrix.
OK, so ready for
the picture now?
That these come into?
You know what the
picture looks like, it's
going to have the
usual four, we'll
start with these potentials u at
the nodes, potentials at nodes,
so those will be
u_1, u_2, u_3, u_4.
Voltages, if I'm
really speaking,
those units would be volts,
and now comes the matrix A.
And now I get, what
do I get from A?
What do I get from A?
Key question.
If I multiply A times u, and
you know that's coming, right?
If I multiply A times u, so
I'll erase A transpose now,
because we've got that.
So there's A, and now I'll
make space to multiply by u,
alright?
So now I want to look at Au.
So A multiplies a
bunch of potentials,
a bunch of voltages.
And let's just do
this multiplication
and see what it produces.
This is the great
thing about matrices,
they produce something.
OK, what's the first
component of Au?
Of course, Au is going
to be five by five.
It's going to be
associated with edges.
Right, u's associated
with nodes, Au with edges.
Just, the pattern is so nice.
Alright, what's the
first component?
Just do that multiplication
and what do you get?
u_2-u_1.
What do you get in
the second component?
Do that multiplication
and you get u_3-u_1.
The third one will be u_3-u_2.
The fourth one would be
u_4-u_2, and the fifth one
will be u_4-u_3.
Just like our first
difference matrices.
But this one deals with, I mean,
our first difference matrices
were exactly like this when
the graph was all in a line.
The big step now is that
the graph is not in a line,
not even necessarily in a plane.
Could be in, it's a bunch
of points, and edges.
Actually, the position of those
points, we don't have to know
are they in a plane.
I think of them as
nodes and edges.
OK, what's the
natural name for Au?
I would call those potential
differences, right?
Voltage differences.
So that's what we see
here and those will
be e. e_1, e_2, e_3, e_4, e_5.
will be potential or
voltage differences.
Voltage drops, you might say.
Potential differences,
voltage drops.
Oh well, now.
When I say voltage drops, that's
because, as we noted before,
the current goes from a
higher to a lower potential.
It goes in the
direction of the drop.
And I think that what we
need now is minus Au, for e.
So I think we need a minus
sign and it's quite common
to have the minus sign.
We saw it already
with least squares.
And let me say
also, so this is e.
I'll abbreviate those five e's
I just wrote down, five of them.
So you would remember
there are five.
We're talking
about the currents.
We're talking about,
this is the e in E=IR.
The electromotive--
The voltage drop.
That makes some current go.
Now, also, just as
with least squares,
so it was great that
we saw it before,
there could be a
source term here.
So I'm completing the picture
here, allowing the source term.
And we'll come back to what
does that mean, physically.
But at that point could
enter b, and b is really
standing for batteries.
I work hard to make the
language match the initials.
These letters.
OK, now what?
That step just involved
A, nothing physical.
Now comes the step that
involves C, so w will be Ce.
And these will be the
currents on the edges.
And that's the law,
then, with a matrix C,
of course C is our
old friend c_1 to c_5.
And tell me first the name.
Whose law is this?
That the current is proportional
to the voltage drop?
Ohm.
So this is Ohm's law.
Instead of Hooke's
law, it's Ohm's law.
And I've written it with
conductances, not resistances.
So resistances are 1 over-- R,
the usual R in E=IR, would be--
I'm more looking at it
as I, current, equals Ce,
instead of E=IR.
So I'm flipping the, the, the
resistance, or the impedance
to give the conductance.
OK, and now finally
can you tell me
what the last step
is going to be?
If life is good, well you might
wonder whether life is good,
reading the papers, but
it's still good here.
OK, what matrix shows up there?
Everybody knows it.
A transpose.
So the final equation,
the balance equation,
will be, let me write it so
I don't catch it up here.
Will be A transpose
w equals whatever.
Will be the balance equation.
The current balance,
it's the balance
of currents, balance of charge,
whatever you like to say.
At each node, it's the
balance at the nodes.
Because when we're
up on this line,
we're in the node picture.
We have four
equations here, right?
We're talking
about at each node.
Here we're talking
about on each edge.
There it's so critical.
These two variables.
Which we're seeing physically
as node variables and edge
variables.
That pair of variables
just shows up everywhere.
In displacements and stresses,
it's fundamental in elasticity.
And oh, there are just
so many in optimization,
it's everywhere.
And a big part of this course
is to see it everywhere.
OK, why don't I, just so
you see the main picture.
We're going to have the A
transpose C A matrix that I'm
going to maybe call K again.
And now of course there
could be current sources.
Just the way there could be
forces that we had to balance.
There could be, not
always but there could be,
current sources from outside.
External current sources.
So these are external
voltage sources.
These are external
current sources.
So in a way, we now have
combined our first two
examples, our springs and
masses only had forces external.
Our least squares problem
had an external b.
Measurements.
This picture is the whole deal.
It's got b and f, and
actually I could put in
even a little more.
Sources like, well, we already
kind of caught on to the fact
that we'd better ground the
node or A transpose C A,
as it stands, A transpose C A
as it stands will be singular.
You know, it's the matrix,
there's A transpose A
and the C in the middle
isn't going to help any.
That's singular.
If we wanted to be able
to compute voltages,
we've got to set one of them.
It's like setting
one temperature,
it's like deciding
where is absolute zero.
Let's put absolute
zero down here. u_4=0.
Grounded the node.
OK, so we've fixed a potential.
So here's a boundary
condition coming in u_4=0.
That's another source
term, another thing coming,
you could say sort of from
outside the A transpose C
A. We could fix
another voltage at,
I mean, I'm thinking now
about what's the picture.
What's the whole problem?
So the problem could have
batteries, in the edges.
It could have current
sources into the nodes.
It could fix u_1 at
some voltage like ten.
Our problem could fix--
We must fix one of them.
Otherwise our matrix
isn't-- is singular.
But once we've
set up the matrix,
and when we fix
u_4=0 by the way,
what happens to our matrix?
Let me take u_4=0, so
this is a key step here.
When I set u_4=0,
I now know u_4.
It's not an unknown any more.
So I've removed u_4
from the problem.
And then it'll be also
removed from A transpose A.
So this, is you could
say, like a reduced A,
or a grounded matrix A.
It's now five by three.
And A transpose
A, what shape will
the a transpose a matrix be?
It'll be three by three, right?
I now have five by
three, three by five.
Multiplying five by three
gives me three by three.
This column is gone,
and that row is gone.
Because the row came from
A transpose and the column
came from A, and we've
just thrown them away.
By grounding that node.
Now give me the key fact about
that A transpose A matrix?
What do you see there?
Now, you see a reduced,
a grounded A transpose A.
What kind of a
matrix have I got?
Positive definite.
Good.
It's now not singular
any more, its determinant
is some positive number.
And everything is positive, its
eigenvalues are all positive,
everything's good
about that matrix.
OK, and I guess what I
was starting to say here,
if I wanted to fix, this
would be a natural problem.
Fix the top voltage at one, say.
Fix u_1=1 and see how
much current flows.
That would be a
natural question.
What's the system resistance
between the top node
and the bottom, if I'm given--
Or the system conductance.
If I'm given a c_1, a c_2,
a c_3 a c_4 and a c_5,
I could say I could fix
that voltage at one,
I could fix this at zero.
Maybe one of the
homework problems
asks you for
something like this.
And then you find
all the currents.
And the voltages, you
solve the problem.
And you know what
the currents are.
You know the total current
that leaves node one,
enters node four when the
voltages drop by one between,
right?
So current can flow down
here, cross over here,
down here whatever.
Somehow all these
five numbers are
going to play a part in
that system resistance.
So that would be an
interesting number to know.
Out of those five
numbers, somehow five c's,
there's a system resistance
between that node
and that node.
And we can find it by
setting this to be one,
this to be zero, having the
reduced matrix-- Oh, well
what will happen?
How many unknowns will I have?
Just do this mental experiment.
Suppose I introduce u_1
to be one, for example.
This is just one type
of possible problem.
If I take u_1 to be one,
what happens to my matrix A?
It loses its first column, too.
u_1 is not unknown any more.
u_1 will not be unknown.
And that value one
is somehow going
to move to the
right-hand side, right?
People have asked
me after class, well
what happens if a boundary
condition isn't zero?
Suppose we have
this fixed springs
and we pull this spring down
to make its displacement 12.
Well, somehow that 12
is going to show up
on the right side
of the equation.
It's a source, it's
an external term.
OK, so if we had
u_1 equals whatever,
this u_1 would disappear.
I would only have a
two by two problem.
Because I would
only have two, I now
have only two
unknown u's, right?
So that's where
sources can come.
And can I just complete the
picture of the source stuff?
We could fix, we could.
Look, here's what
I'm going to say.
External stuff.
Sources can come into here.
They can come into here.
They can come into here,
so of course everybody
says why shouldn't
they come in here?
And the answer is we
could send them here.
So we could fix, we
could fix some w's.
Of course, you understand
we can't do everything.
I mean, there's a limit to how
much we can put on the system.
We want to have
some unknowns left.
Some matrix still, but anyway.
I like this picture
now, it's more complete.
That you now see the node
variables and node equations,
the edge variables, e and w.
The currents.
These guys are the
big ones. w and u
are what I think of as
the crucial unknowns.
e is sort of on the
way. f is the source.
But now we have the
possibility of sources
at all four positions.
OK, let's see.
If I wrote out, If I
looked at A transpose C A,
would you like to tell me, yeah.
Have we got?
No, we don't.
I was going to say, what's a
typical row of A transpose C A,
can I just say it in words?
It'll be too quick
to really catch.
So without the C,
this is what we had.
So what do you think
that two becomes
if there's an A transpose C A,
if there's a C in the middle.
Have you got the pattern yet?
That two was there
because of two edges.
Edges one and two,
it happened to be.
So instead of the two,
I'm going to see c_1+c_2.
Right.
When those were
ones, I got the two.
So this will be c_1+c_2,
this'll be a minus c_1,
and that'll be a minus
c_2, when we do it out.
And you could do it
out for yourself.
Just tell me what
would show up there.
In A transpose C A, so I'm
talking now about A transpose C
A. So instead of one plus
one plus one, what do I have?
What am I going to have, and you
really want to multiply it out,
because it's so nice
to see it happen.
What do I have?
I'm looking at node two, I'm
seeing three edges out of it.
And instead of one, one,
one, I'll have c_1+c_3+c_4.
c_1+c_3+c_4 will
be sitting here.
And minus c_1 will be here,
and minus c_3 will be here,
and minus c_4 will be there.
The pattern's just nice.
So if you can read this
part of the section,
I'll have more to say
Friday about the A transpose
w, the balance.
That critical point
we didn't do yet.
But the main thing,
you've got it.